hey guys welcome to my home I hope you
are still staying active from the
comfort of your own home I know that
most of us can't even get out of our
house but today I want to share with you
a total body call and cardio workout
okay you do not need anything at all
just you and your body because your body
is your best tool so there will be two
circuits all right
really simple workouts but it's going to
challenge you each circuit there will be
four exercises and each workout will be
for 45 seconds long with 15 seconds rest
in between
all right so let's get to it let's warm
our body up to begin with just Stan you
know this with your shoulder width apart
knees pointed forward and just give me a
nice deep squat very good
so we're warming up the entire body
prepping ourselves for lots of explosive
movements keep going squatting down
pushing your butt back with your toes
pointed forward you won't need to wear
your shoes at home and very good
open up the hips give me three more one
last two and three again working with
our legs as well as hip flexor let's
take a step forward lunge and push back
lunge and push back stand tall all right
very good
stand tall and reach up keep going I'm
filming this just on my own no camera
cool no nothing but let's do this
workout together one more on each side
and very good
okay just warming up the upper body stop
at the edge of your mat and now I want
you to slowly inch forward into a high
plank position Pike your butt up stretch
your back out stretch your calves back
into a plank and slowly inch back good
against slowly into a high plank Pike
your butt up into a downward dog plank
and slowly inch back and up
give me one more high plank pike it up
plank and come back up all right very
good so as you can see I don't have lots
of space so we want to really minimize
moving around too much the first workout
is going to be a new to squat so what I
want to do is start low in a kneeling
position and push yourself up into a
squat position back down on your knees
and up very good
superb maintaining a low position at all
times back it down and push yourself up
and down so alternating the legs okay
left leg right leg good starting off
nice and easy left up and down if you
feel that this is too much on your knees
you can add another layer of mat just to
reduce the impact on your knees
okay up and back down give me two more
back up and down you should really start
to feel your face working and back it
down okay shake it up right let's that
let's stop at the front of your mat we
want to work with new driver so what I'm
going to do is take a step back as you
come up drive in the up step back and
drive your knee up good just on your
left side okay drive your knee up post
point sit down and drive your knee up
very good so working on one side step
back up push it up stand tall and up do
the squeeze on your right gluts step
back and up good keep going
whew working on one side also working on
your balance as well as your core I love
this workout it really challenges my
core it really work on my thighs and my
glutes the push back up last few more
keep going
up down
up nice one more and up very good
okay now let's get down onto the floor
all right who has done for my plank
challenge we want to incorporate that
today so it's going to be two plank
jacks and one knee tuck all right let's
go to plank jacks one knee tuck in out
and to plank jacks one knee tuck in and
out very good keep going
whoop so working on your hips and
working on your app scrunch it in feel
your whole working punch it in
good in woof high energy let's bring our
energy up even from your home ha let me
know which country you're doing this
workout from keep going last few more in
that's one more in and just get back up
okay let's do a little bit of at work by
standing up so it's great to be a squat
and a twist
okay so again stand shoulder width apart
hands up
squat down twist and drag your knee to
your elbow remember it's about bringing
your knee to your elbow very good and
this is the final workout for the first
second right after this we want to
repeat the entire circuit once more just
another four minutes and I promise you
you will get a rest
good so working on your core it's not
just about doing crunches it's not just
about lying down on the floor but you
can also work by standing up okay keep
going
few more twists drive your knee to your
elbow last one and back down okay
first workout new to squat okay so you
can choose your option start in a
kneeling position and come back up or
for those of you who want to take this
workout to the next level let's hop
Sonne squat back down and energy up back
down use the momentum use the power from
your legs to push yourself into a squat
very good one of my favorite exercises
as well to really work on your power
explode Oh
breathe out very good let's go breathe
out and down again breathe out and down
good job remember keeping your chest up
and open Oh keep going
explode now you know how strong your
legs are up down one last one up and
shake it out okay new driver so we've
worked on our right leg this time let's
work on our left side so step forward
now bring your right leg back okay step
back up step back and up good sorry
wrong side up step back and up so
working on your left thigh and your left
glute up push it in up keep going
find your balance really suck that belly
in tighten your core and find that focal
point okay
I remember breathe out when it's tough
so breathe in down breathe out when
you're pushing up breathe out in out the
more you have the better you are at
pacing a breathing the easier the
workout will be let's get back down onto
plank so it's going to be two plank
jacks and one knee tucks alright
stand up high plate three more seconds
and let's go one two in and out one two
are you already feeling the burner very
good
see it's only you and your body let's
get this done
I love this thing a short workout is
better than no workout so wherever
you're at whatever your plans are fit in
a short workout session okay let's do
this let's stay strong 15 seconds left
keep pushing whew dripping feeling
awesome
keep going crunch in crunch up last one
more crunch in out and get back ahh oh
my gosh
one final workout and you will get a
shot brick Oh
spending crunches okay
stop in a squat position let's go down
twist remember to aim to drive your knee
as high as you can all right
haha I remember to just breathe pace
your breathing do not drop your arms
keep your arms up keep your elbows open
and just keep going
whoop push your butt back core and
cardio oh what is killer combo keep
going you got ten more seconds and you
will get a one-minute break oh that's
two more that's one more and rest it out
okay take this moment to just breathe in
breathe out
drink some water if you need to wipe
your sweat and we have one more circuit
I am feeling crazy at home do you know
what the funny thing is I thought that
I'm going to struggle to enjoy my home
workouts but in fact I've been enjoying
it a lot more and I've been doing a lot
of the workouts from Theo which is my
fitness app so even if you haven't yet
downloaded your do check it out okay
it's available both on the App Store and
Google Play and we've kept the
subscription really low to make sure
that each and every one of us can stay
active at home as low as $5 a month
alright I hope you're still feeling
strong for getting some water the next
is going to be to squat jumps with a
sprawl okay so again 45 seconds three
two one let's go squat jump and back
down into a sprawl all the way up squat
jump back down chest touching the floor
up push up back down again nice push
yourself up power up energy up and back
down let's go explode back down come on
guys you got this whoo if you have an a
body you're an athlete okay so each and
every one of us is an athlete that's one
more up up sprawl up
and rest oh okay next workout it's going
to be punches with explosive lunges okay
so I'm gonna show you from the side left
right and we want to jump down explode
explode okay let's do that
we're left right down alternate and back
up energy up good if you find this too
challenging you can remove the explosive
the safe movement and just give me rebus
line just okay if not let's go left
right down push back push back up left
right very good strong arms strong
shoulders twist your core as you punch
whoop my legs my legs
haha let me know in the comments below
how you're feeling right now and press
it alright okay back roll we're gonna
take the workout done one not but it is
still active active start at the edge of
your mat get into all fours okay in this
position crawl forward okay as far as
you can
four steps and crawl back the goal is to
not hike your butt up so don't do this
this is wrong
keep it low maintaining in a flat back
position
crawl forward and crawl back very good
just like a Hungry Bear keep going whoop
nice
oh my god New York or vo Lakes after
your HUD rate pumping that's one more
let's go one more time forward back and
rest okay another plank challenge for
you this time it's going to behave like
rock okay so get into a low plank
position alright check it back that it's
flat now let's rock forward and back
push yourself as far forward as you can
and all the way back good keep going
really engage your core
feel your body shaking good that means
your muscles are working keep going push
forward and back forward and back
alright now let's go hip dip left to
right left to right
fifteen more seconds on the clock and
it's back to the first workout for the
second circuit
a few more keep dipping left right and
get back up if only you can see how
sweaty I am right now okay let's do this
okay - squat jumps and one sprawl
remember chest down squat jump remember
to bend your knees as you land okay it's
very important to keep your knees bent
to avoid any unwanted injuries up up
down push yourself up this is your final
four minutes
push-up
few more guys trust me every time I feel
my workout it is not as easy I feel your
pain rest it out okay huh next a little
bit of kickboxing moves which is also I
have to say my favorite form of cardio
okay so left leg forward right leg back
I'm up left right to some record down
into a lunge explode twice back up toys
from it's also okay up and back up twist
down huh keep going guys
do not stop right now if this is too
much take it down one notch and get into
reverse lunges Oh sweaty keep going
last fifteen more seconds let's try to
get two more in let's go last one more
down and shake it out okay back row but
at the edge of your mat okay remember
keep your back flat and just lift your
knees off the floor slightly let's go
forward okay really through your thighs
your glutes as you maintain a low plank
position keep going
take this time so so slow down your
breathing pacer breathing drive your
knee to your elbow and slowly inch back
into elbow and inch back you got this
we're almost there
last ten seconds okay and after this do
me a favor and clean up your match
that's one more forward and just take a
quick breather
okay last workout which is also a plank
challenge all right plank rock forward
and back and a hip dip side to side
let's go last 45 seconds breathe in out
in and out in and out very good
keep going
and last one more let's go left and
right remember to not Pike your butt up
okay nineteen a strong plank position
and just dip your hip as low as you can
from the left to the right
a few more you're almost there
two one
very very very well done let me know how
you got on with this workout in the
comments below okay I hope that you
asked this thing active daily from the
comfort of your own home
alright so do also check out my 21 days
at home workout okay I've created that
for you guys because I want each and
every one of you to stay active from the
comfort of your own home and if you want
more videos let me know in the comments
below don't forget to also hit the
subscribe button give this video a
thumbs up like this video and share this
workout on and I will see you in my next
home workout absolutely drenched amazing
job guys are the best